[Musique]
bonsoir shadwick mot merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france à l'instant
il ya quelques secondes joe biden a
réagi et s'est levée de restrictions
notamment évidemment au texas les
qualifiant d' une pensée préhistorique
on voit qu'il ya une guerre qui
s'instaure entre le président qui veut
faire de la lutte anti qu'ovide sa
priorité il l'a toujours dit et certains
gouverneurs qui n'entendent pas les
choses de la même façon au texas et
d'autres états comme la floride qui
s'est ouverte à uba témoin qui s'est
débarrassée des masques
il ya des lois et il n'y a pas eu de
catastrophe
suite à la réouverture dans le texas et
un autre pays qui un autre état qui
récupère sa liberté et d'autres tandis
que la géorgie de suivre sans être si
c'est un pitre et un état très peuplée
et la californie également se retrouvent
dans des situations du film est en cours
dans les deux états comme une fois qu'on
peut sortir mais la vie est très
différent qu'auparavant et pourtant elle
ne convient de toujours là toujours des
hospitalisations et des décès les
résultats montrent en floride et dans
d'autres états que ce confinement ne
fait que blesser nos colonies et
la santé psychique des gens elle je base
elle n'aime pas parler de cela il y à
plus d'utilisateurs de drogue il ya plus
de suicides isolement d'un succès genre
depuis plus d'un an est très dur va
commencer par dire qu'il fasse confinés
pendant quelques mois pour ralentir la
propagation et maintenant cela fait un
an les états républicains forte et sans
suivre leur propre foi et c'est la façon
un système fonctionne états unis chaque
brique moore c'est finalement deux
visions se sont finalement deux visions
qui s'affrontent
peut-être celle des démocrates et celle
des républicains ça nous rappelle en
tout cas clairement la campagne
présidentielle où donald trump et et
voilà pour les libertés pour maintenir
l'économie et une certaine forme de
liberté publique oppose évidemment la
vision de joe biden pendant la campagne
les deux messages de républicains et
démocrates étaient très différents le
message de donald trump était optimiste
il voulait aller de l'avant progresser
avancé réouvrir aussi rapidement que
possible relancer l'économie remettre
les enfants à l'école
le message de joe bayonne avant son
élection était celui d'un à l'univers
sombre avenir il disait que
l'association elle est devenue pire
avant de s'améliorer
donc ces deux visions des deux parties
effectivement sont aussi résumé très
simplement
il ya beaucoup de pression sur joe biden
pour que les états restent fermées mais
bien sûr cela et voit le chèque
les parents démocrates comme des
républicains veulent que leurs enfants
reviennent savez comme une place que les
écoles rouvrent et joe biden a commencé
à dire que au niveau fédéral il allait
suggérer que les professeurs soient
priorisées pour la vaccination
effectivement ce sont deux visions des
deux partis le parti républicain veut
plus de liberté rouvrir l'économie
l'autre parti le parti démocrate veut un
confinement est en laine des masques les
uns sur les autres
1 2 3 30 masques apporter à la fois il
ya des personnalités par exemple comme
pato ni fochi qu'ils sont aimés par les
démocrates est détesté par les
républicains d'autres personnes lisent
le confinement pourrait durer encore un
an pourrait durer jusqu'en 2022 avant
que la situation redevienne normale
les républicains eux n'acceptaient pas
c'est là donc c'est vraiment la grande
fracture des visions de ce pays entre
deux approches deux parties la façon
dont il voit le meilleur moyen d'avancer
et cela se cristallise autour de la
réponse là cofide alors en tout cas de
joe biden essaye de tenir ses promesses
et veulent mettre le paquet dans la
lutte contre le coc vide le président
qui vient d'annoncer que l'objectif de
vaccination pour tous les adultes et
bien ce serait finalement fin mai avec
plus jouer à la faveur de l'accord avec
johnson & johnson c'est un objectif qui
est très ambitieux comment est il perçu
aux états unis effectivement commencé
par dire fin juillet ce qui avait pas ma
surprise et
ces serres maintenant dans la loi sur la
production de défense pour essayer de
raccourcir le calendrier jusqu'à la fin
mais il bénéficie des efforts de donald
femmes concernant les respirateurs les
équipements de production personnelle
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais autour de
moi les gens ne sont pas très
enthousiastes
les gens en ont marre de la côte est
venu le plus en parler douze mois les
gens en bonne santé qui veulent à tout
prix ce vaccin sont une petite minorité
très brillante la majorité des gens même
temps des lieux très libérée comme à new
york sont inquiètes
c'est des fariboles et une continue de
suivre cette politique de porter le
masque parce que c'est ce qu'on est
censé faire parce que c'est ce coup de
boule à maman l'ordi et de gouvernement
celui que tout le monde donc la
vaccination d'ici à fin mai c'est en
bleu mais les gens ont aussi s'y
intéressent patrons ils sont prêts à
reprendre la vie normale des
républicains de leur propre chef les
démocrates concernant le dire ça veut
dire clairement j'avais de bons que aux
états unis selon ces cas là c'est très
grand les états unis bien sûr et qui a
certainement différentes opinions mais
contrairement à l'europe les gens ne
sont pas si le demandeur que ça quant à
la vaccination parce que évidemment ici
on râle beaucoup à cause de la pénurie
des vaccins vous ne ressentez pas la
même chose
aux états unis il ya sans doute un peu
plus de scepticisme envers le vaccin aux
états unis mais il même aux états unis
il y a des gens qui sont influençables
qui suivent l'autorité de très près je
ne pense pas que l'obligation de se
faire vacciner ce n'est acceptée aux
états unis je suis mais certaines
industries certaines entreprises
pourrait demander avec ses obligataires
par exemple les compagnies aériennes et
les américains seraient forcés de suivre
car elle ne pourrait pas normal c'est en
cela que nous ne sommes pas en passe
d'avoir des pénuries de varades estrie
bution c'est pas ça au départ cela
semblait difficile par exemple à new
york
on entendait parler de vaccin qui est
amenée à la poubelle parce qu'on ne
réussissait pas à les conserver et à les
distribuer correctement le qu'il ya sans
doute plus de scepticisme aux états unis
mais c'est une simple différence
culturelle entre les états unis et
d'autres pays le gens aux états unis
elles sont plus confortables avec l'idée
d'une homme était naturel sachant que
cela signifie tombée malade deux locaux
vides elles se remettent un thuram ans
et être protégé plutôt que de devoir se
faire injecter un vaccin développé en un
temps record et qui pour beaucoup de
personnes semble encore assez
expérimental sachant que certains
vaccins ont nécessité des décennies à
être développé tant qu'il ya cet ce
scepticisme après beaucoup de personnes
la copie 19 qui est pas si effrayante
que ça sauf pour les personnes très
malades ou très âgés
c'est cela peut influencer les décisions
aux états unis merci beaucoup chadebech
mots j'en ai x politique nous avoir
exposé donc la situation aux états unis
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir